[Musica]
[Applauso]
domanda mega semplice quanta co2
produciamo ogni anno la domanda super
difficile ovviamente non abbiamo la
minima idea di quanta co2
produciamo ogni anno non è un calcolo
che normalmente facciamo partiamo da un
numero un po più semplice 19 g 19 grammi
alla quantità di co2 che mettiamo
facendo un'azione che facciamo
praticamente ogni giorno più volte al
giorno è un'azione che si può dire siamo
solo se anche se non siamo in fascia
protetta 19 g
la quantità di co2 che mettiamo quando
inviamo una mail con un megabyte di
allegato una roba del genere nel senso
che mandare una mail deve passare
attraverso numerosi server che
richiedono energia elettrica
questa energia elettrica viene prodotta
nella stragrande maggioranza dei casi da
fonti fossili e quindi mettiamo co2
facciamo finta che mandiamo non lo so 5
mail al giorno 100 grammi un piatto di
pasta praticamente se questa cosa se noi
lavoriamo tutti i giorni della settimana
diventa una settimana di vento 500
grammi 5 piatti di basta la portiamo su
un anno questa cosa diventa 25 kg vuol
dire che noi mettiamo 25 kg di co2 solo
mandando le mail che probabilmente la
cosa che pensiamo che metta di meno
nella storia mandare le mele rispetto a
un postino ora perché la co2 dovrebbe
mandarci molto più in paranoia per
esempio dei carboidrati per esempio
perché la concentrazione attuale di co2
in atmosfera è questa qua 400 15,26
parti per milione a maggio 2019 e tanto
e poco cioè dov'è che dobbiamo guardare
il limite che noi non dovremmo superare
e 450 parti per milione fuoco vuol dire
brutto vuol dire che se andiamo oltre
alle 450 parti per milione
andremo oltre questo famigerato aumento
di temperatura media globale di più 1,5
gradi
ora quanta co2 stiamo immettendo in
atmosfera la risposta è tanta questi
sono gli ultimi 50 anni
più o meno due particelle ma anche 34
particelle di co2 per milione ogni anno
cos'è che fa la co2 la co2 aumenta
l'effetto serra
l'effetto serra e cattivo no l'effetto
serra è buono non è cattivo grazie
all'effetto serra non abbiamo meno 18
gradi sul pianeta terra praticamente non
siamo come i ghiaccioli all'interno del
freezer grazie all'effetto serra abbiamo
una temperatura media globale di più 13
gradi
il problema ovviamente è l'aumento
dell'effetto serra che crea questo
famigerato aumento cioè la temperatura
media globale che quella roba lì che
vediamo molto intensa negli ultimi anni
da questo grafico si vede invece ancora
meglio da questo grafico da questo si
vede ancora meglio come sia
clamorosamente correlato
l'aumento di co2 in giallo con la
temperatura che varia ma va aumentare
continuamente siamo arrivati ormai a più
1,1 gradi di aumento di temperatura
media globale e questa cosa signori ci
riguarda molto da vicino perché noi in
italia e nel bacino del mediterraneo
siamo arrivati ormai a come vedete il
c'è la zona rossa attorno e siamo
arrivati ap 1,58 gradi di temperatura
media globale un grado non è che ci fa
davvero effetto cioè cosa vuol dire un
grado di aumento di temperatura ha
trovato un modo molto più efficiente
molto efficace per far capire quanta
energia che abbiamo inserito in
atmosfera ed è signori sono un grande
classico le bombe atomiche come se
avessimo inserito dal 1998 qualcosa come
2 miliardi 743 milioni e rotti bombe
atomiche in atmosfera non stupiamoci se
poi gli uragani sono giusto un
pochettino più potenti poi certo insomma
come qualcuno diceva prima possiamo
avere gli eventi di freddo a livello
locale
fa freddo non c'è riscaldamento globale
che è un po come dire ho appena mangiato
due tv carbonara dove la fame nel mondo
e ovvio che gli stomaci locali a livello
globale gli eventi locali non possono
corrispondere a un trend globale e il
trend globale va avanti dagli ultimi 150
anni
guardiamo gli ultimi mille anni si vede
chiaramente come le temperature siano
sempre variate leggermente ma mai così
tanto come gli ultimi 100 anni
maniera così intensa torniamo ancora un
po indietro 800.000 anni si il clima è
sempre cambiato la co2 e la temperatura
sono sempre cambiati
ma mai così tanto in maniera così
intensa facciamo un passo ancora
indietro 55 milioni di anni fa c'era
questa concentrazione di co2 le
temperature molto più elevate
la situazione totalmente diversa avevamo
già lì sotto anche voleva della break
sit l'europa era già divisa non potevamo
andare direttamente in india l'india
lontana my friends insomma la situazione
era molto diversa ma noi li non
c'eravamo
non ci eravamo lì è questa cosa doveva
farci capire che non è un problema da
ambientalisti questa bellissima ho visto
che sei un ambientalista non sembra che
vogliamo andare abbracciare gli alberi e
salvare il parchetto nulla contro chi
vuole abbracciare gli alberi ovviamente
ma la crisi climatica signori sarà il
più grande cambiamento climatico
economico geopolitico e sociale della
storia dell'uomo perché abbraccia
praticamente tutti tutti i temi che
conosciamo che sono una marea di temi e
il tema della giustizia climatica sarà
essenziale e quando qualcuno dice ma la
specie umana potrebbe scomparire sembra
molto da catastrofi sembra un po
esagerato tre esempi molto rapidi del
perché tutto quanto potrebbe
effettivamente collassare tre tempi
rapidissimi primo esempio i ghiacciai
dell'himalaya i ghiacciai dell'himalaya
danno da bere a qualcosa come un
miliardo di persone tutti questi quattro
di questi qua devo nodali agli acciai
piace cambiare quando si sciolgono però
un certo punto collassano come faceva
quello in val d'aosta circa qualche mese
fa ecco se questi ghiacciai collassasse
rowe avremo un miliardo di persone che
non hanno più da bere tipo oppure un
altro esempio molto banale la
groenlandia o gli assi antartici se si
scioglie la groenlandia signore abbiamo
più sette metri di aumento del livello
del mare
avremo queste città che già al 2050
rischiano di essere sommerse circa circa
un miliardo di persone che si trovano
l'acqua in casa e non basterà fare i
risvolti ni oppure il permafrost in
siberia
abbiamo delle bombe di latrati di metano
si chiamano che sono contenuti
all'interno del permafrost in siberia
se questo si scioglierà e non sappiamo
quando avverrà si libererebbe in
atmosfera una bomba di metano che 72
volte più potente come gas serra della
co2
benvenuti come dice il ceo di axa
assicurazioni dice giustamente un mondo
con 4 gradi di aumento di temperatura è
semplicemente un mondo non più
assicurabile se vai a chiedere agli
scienziati dell'ipad cosa succederà più
4 gradi dicono ignoto non lo sappiamo
cosa volete
ci sono talmente tante dinamiche che
rischiano entrare in ballo che
semplicemente non siamo in grado di
prevederlo ora questa cosa riguarda
anche noi molto da vicino 33 città
italiane un terzo del decreto rischia di
essere sommerso al 2100 i danni
all'agricoltura italiana non si contano
già più
il vino nelle vigne si contano
tantissimi danni
ora questa cosa è ancora più grave forse
di fronte a noi questo è il deserto del
sahara e quello in giallo ai deserti
piace espandersi nella fascia del sahel
questa desertificazione sta portando
conseguenze devastanti
ci sono già milioni di persone che si
stanno muovendo ii e la cia la cia
considera i cambiamenti climatici come
la più grande è causa di instabilità a
livello geopolitico
non è un caso che in queste regioni boko
haram e terrorismi generale trovi
terreno molto fertile perché crea una
marea di instabilità domanda delle
domande come diceva sempre mahmood soldi
quanto costa quanto costa limitare la
crisi climatica
ora la domanda che noi dovremmo porci è
qual è il costo dell'azione contro il
costo dell'inazione contro crisi
climatica e questo signore è nordhaus
premio nobel per l'economia hanno fatto
questi calcoli ho letto che i signori
nei prossimi anni ci costerà un bel po
di soldi una cosa come il 5 6 7 8 per
cento del pil globale per i prossimi
decenni
quello in blu ma noi non agiamo i costi
potrebbero essere clamorosamente più
elevati anche il 30 40 50 per cento del
pil globale
ora noi siamo in questa situazione e gli
scenari che ci si parano davanti sono
decisamente differenti cioè quello in
verdi a 1,5 che meraviglia molto molto
difficile arrivare a fine secolo con pil
gradi
dovremmo veramente sperarci attualmente
con le politiche stiamo buttando in atto
siamo qua tratta del 3,7 ma potrebbero
esserci serenamente conseguenze molto
peggiori anche a 4,1 più 4,8 gradi di
aumento di temperatura media globale
questa è la curva delle riduzioni cioè
quanto rapidamente dobbiamo smettere di
emettere ora se avessimo cominciato un
po di anni fa nel 2000 lo scivolo si è
in piedi però un kamikaze ma ancora lo
fai più o meno più vai avanti più il
kamikaze diventa veramente veramente in
piedi e diventerà sempre più arduo è
sempre più ripido la curva di riduzione
delle emissioni che dovremo
intraprendere domanda da cento milioni
di dollari
siamo sicuri che sia l'uomo ora abbiamo
praticamente tutte le certezze ma c'è
questo studio abbastanza recente che è
stato fatto e cosa hanno fatto un detto
che ai questo è l'impatto umano quindi
la temperatura che cresce in rosso ha
detto proviamo in questo mega modello
tramite machine learning e altre cose
brutte
a togliere l'impatto umano la forzante
umana la co2 che noi abbiamo inserito
togliere dallo scenario è questo il
risultato cioè se noi non avessimo
inserito la nostra co2
questo sarebbe risultato a temperatura
non sarebbe variata ora quanta co2
possiamo mettere ancora a testa cioè noi
qua voi quanto ci possiamo mettere
considerando un aumento della
popolazione 2050
possiamo arrivare a qualcosa come 100
tonnellate di co2 adesso che tra tante
per avere attenzione il 66 per cento di
possibilità di non oltrepassare i 2
gradi che vorrei sapere chi salirebbe su
un aereo con il 66 per cento di
proprietà di arrivare a casa ora quanta
co2 emettiamo noi personalmente a testa
ogni anno facciamo facciamo sondaggio
facciamo sul taglio è qualcuno in questa
stanza al fratello ha una casa magari
anche con l'acqua calda che lusso
allora se abbiamo una casa con l'acqua
calda e mettiamo qualcosa come 1,5
tonnellate di co2 a testa all'anno
altra domanda qualcuno mangia è che se
mangiate magari mangiano anche carne che
ci sta 2,5 tonnellate di co2 a testa
all'anno
qualcuno prende degli aerei
magari non tanti quanti human safari ma
un aereo in volo milano new york sono
una tonnellata di co2 per un volo o
qualcuno dei vestiti qualcuno un
cellulare illuso e l'acquisto di beni
non servizi e circa una tonnellata
oppure usiamo una macchina circa una
tonnellata e mezza testa l'uso di
servizi ospedali strade e cose del
genere
circa un'altra formulata per un totale
di 8,5 9 tonnellate di co2 a testa ora
queste situazioni squisitamente
personali che solo noi possiamo decidere
di cambiare per fortuna io dico se tutti
quanti volessimo agire in questa
direzione potremo arrivare a comprimere
arrivare circa 3 tonnellate di co2 a
testa all'anno una roba del genere
isolare la nostra casa mangiare molta
molta meno caro arrivare vegetariani
usare meno la r eccetera
ora lo step successivo per il sistema in
cui viviamo è praticamente andare a
vivere una grotta
dopodichè difficile comprimere le
missioni più di così
la differenza fra questi 93 facciamo 100
tonnellate che possiamo mettere ancora
destra cento diviso 8,5 fa quei dieci
anni qualcosina per cui arriviamo al
2030 il famoso anno della fine del mondo
no il mondo non esploderà nel 2030 ma il
2030 potrebbe essere il famoso punto di
non ritorno cioè il punto oltre il quale
non saremo più in grado di limitare di
mitigare i cambiamenti climatici ma
ancora 100 devi sottrae fa 33 33 anni
gli anni di gesù non solo tanti ancora
33 anni con questo studio e di vita di
mettere cosa significa sta roba qua
perché questo giochino significa che se
volete farvi un tatuaggio o un tag
automi gallo vuol farci un murales
facciamo che scriviamo le azioni
personali da sole non bastano più non
bastano assolutamente più servono altri
tipi di soluzioni ora quali sono le
soluzioni
mi sono permesso di utilizzare un
animazione all'interno di questa
presentazione non esiste una soluzione
non esiste una soluzione nel senso che
esistono tante soluzioni tante soluzioni
e tutte queste soluzioni vanno
necessariamente implementata assieme
necessariamente la prima soluzione tutte
la cooperazione internazionale famosi
accordi di parigi 2015 per la prima
volta abbiamo deciso di dire ok
forse potremmo limitare l'aumento di
temperatura a 2 gradi meglio 1,5 altre
soluzioni soluzioni tecniche le
conosciamo project gioco dow hanno messo
in fila questi ricercatori le 100
soluzioni più efficaci che possiamo
utilizzare noi siamo la causa per
fortuna noi possiamo essere dobbiamo
essere la soluzione hanno messo in fila
a queste 100 soluzioni in ordine
efficacia e non necessariamente sono
quelle che noi pensiamo siano suspense
però quella in giallo per esempio hanno
a che fare con l'energia e non sono così
tante se ci sono quelle in rosso hanno a
che fare con il cibo e come produciamo
il cibo nuovamente che la carne vegetale
risponde esattamente a questo tipo di
bisogno
colpo di scena a quelli in viola hanno a
che fare con i diritti pazzesco cioè
hanno notato come garantire i diritti
fondamentali come l'accesso
all'educazione a tutte le fasce della
popolazione
in tutto il mondo abbia un effetto
clamoroso sulla riduzione della co2 in
atmosfera sarà quello che fa la
differenza su essere nove o dieci
miliardi al 2050 un miliardo di persone
in più che magari potrebbero anche voler
mangiare tipo quelle cose lì ora altro
tipo di soluzioni la nostra preferita
personale creare consenso creare
consenso però significa questo signore
qua suspense ok questo signore qua
mister obama seconda campagna elettorale
2012 tutti lo tiravano per la giacchetta
affinché si si spostasse su posizioni a
favore dei matrimoni fra persone dello
stesso sesso ma lui non l'ha fatto
appena è stato eletto la approvato cos'è
che era successo nel frattempo nel paese
la maggioranza di persone
le persone che favorevoli ai matrimoni
fra persone successo era passata dal 48
per cento
al 52 per cento si era creato una
maggioranza e obama subito le approvate
ma questa cosa funziona anche signori
funziona anche ad esempio nel mercato
ossia non so se vi ricordate fino a
qualche anno fa rischiamo di morire
tutti per colpa dell'olio di palma una
roba del genere quando abbiamo deciso
che volevamo più comprare i biscottini
all'olio di palma
noi abbiamo smesso di comprarli e loro
hanno smesso di produrli qual è il
problema riguarda la crisi clima
e che noi non pensiamo che questo sia un
problema che ci riguarda ci riguarda
così da vicino la scienza da anni che ce
lo dice che questo è un problema molto
nostro dici guarda clamorosamente da
vicino ma noi non siamo convinti di
questa cosa non siamo convinti non
pensiamo sia un tema che ci riguarda
e allora signori l'unica alternativa per
noi era cominciare a scendere piazza
cominciare a scendere in piazza in dire
signori per noi questo è un tema ci
riguarda molto da vicino è una cosa che
riguarda tutti bisogna agire
urgentemente è ovvio che questo è il
risultato ma l'inizio era ben diverso
l'inizio era questa cosa qua il primo
flight nel sulcis una brescia era questa
gara5 scemi sotto la pioggia
io non c'ero tra l'altro se quando fry
nessuna feature alesia un po più di
scemi un publisher e sono tornato anche
io finalmente poi dalla svizzera con
will smith e save the bears perché le la
birra in generale sarà clamorosamente a
rischio perché i cambiamenti climatici
mini spoiler e terzo fra il suo futuro
il 15 marzo poi ci stava prima mega
marcia globale in giro per il mondo ma
cosa come due milioni di persone in giro
per il mondo 500 mila solo in italia
nazione con più partecipanti
chiusa parentesi seconda marcia globale
24 maggio 19 terza marcia globale 27
settembre 2009 qualcosa come 8 milioni
di persone in giro per il mondo a
chiedere azione e giustizia climatica in
qualcosa come 170 nazioni
questa è la torino chiaramente
impressionante ma c'è roma sibu nei
hamburger campana bangalore
insomma la distribuzione e la
manifestazione a km zero più grande ma
organizzata sul pianeta terra in
qualcosa come 6 mila città
eravamo solo in italia quando e 960
città la roba del genere questa cosa
colpo di scena funziona funziona questo
è un sondaggio e sto fatto in germania e
anche se la gente ok quali sono i due
temi che più vi preoccupano e il tema
dell'ambiente e dei cambiamenti
climatici nella crisi primate che è
stato l'unico in grado di andare
insidiare il tema che da anni dominava
la preoccupazione gli stranieri le
migrazioni integrazione e poi all'inizio
di un 19 poi l'ha superato nelle
preoccupazioni questa cosa è avvenuta
esattamente che in italia attualmente
sondaggio di svg di settembre
nove i cambiamenti climatici la crisi
climatica la prima preoccupazione per
gli italiani ovviamente ancora di più
per i giovanissimi
ora qual è il problema cioè perché
questa cosa non sta funzionando
attualmente perché non la stiamo
raccontando come la crisi che dobbiamo
risolvere urgentemente e sapremo farlo
in realtà se volessimo sapremo farlo
1942 bisognava convincere gli americani
che non era il caso di sprecare benzina
perché si era in guerra e ogni goccia di
benzina
serviva e queste campania meravigliose
quando vai in macchina da solo va in
macchina con hitler
fai parte oggi stessi di un car sharing
club
ok questo è il tipo di comunicazione che
dovremmo avere adesso che trasmette
all'urgenza l'urgenza invece attualmente
la situazione che meno questa governo
italiano emergenza climatica ma insomma
questa cosa si ripete anche con gli
altri con gli altri governi
fortunatamente qualcosa si sta muovendo
non siamo assolutamente immobili
anzi negli ultimi cinque anni sono stati
disinvestiti cioè presi da quei settori
e tolti qualcosa come 11 mila miliardi
di dollari e il trend negli ultimi anni
signori è in clamorosa ascesa e difatti
è per noi una spilla al petto
l'opec si considera come la più grande
minaccia per il suo futuro
parole del presidente dell'opec che noi
se fossero che felici di questa cosa
e questa è difatti sono esattamente
nostra inchiesta del gas di frames
futures per il futuro molto semplici
fuori dal fossile
non esiste che doppia che possiamo
continuare a estrarre a distribuire
combustibili fossili petrolio gas e
carbone come se non ci fosse un domani
altrimenti per l'appunto non ci sarà
questo domani tutti uniti nessuno
escluso
non esiste non si può far pagare questa
crisi climatica a tutti indistintamente
dalle proprie responsabilità
se lo faremo staremo preparando il
terreno per la prossima guerra civile o
mondiale come preferite
rompiamo il silenzio diamo voce la
scienza la cosa che fa più rabbia di
tutti è che questa riduzione delle
emissioni di co2 e zero fisicamente
possibile addio fisicamente possibile
siamo in grado di farlo nonostante
questo nonostante questo lo stiamo
agendo in questa direzione
ora messaggi da portare a casa a cerano
è l'ultima cena appunto la crisi
climatica esiste riguarda noi ci
riguarda molto da vicino
conosciamo le soluzioni per uscire dalla
crisi manca però la volontà politica ed
economica per applicarle serve conoscere
serve consapevolezza ma poi per cambiare
le cose bisogna agire bisogna agire in
questo caso non agire non è una
possibilità contemplata ora gli inglesi
hanno questo modo di dire dans les
enfants changeront cioè quando c'è un
problema gigante nella stanza di cui tu
fai finta di niente
per quanto riguarda la crisi climatica
il problema di questo elefante signori e
che si sta per sedere sopra di noi buona
crisi climatica a tutti
[Applauso]